le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
à la réunion
le chômage touche près de 30% de la
population pour contrer ce fléau le
département soutient les dispositifs
d'insertion le glaive est une
association qui propose aux chercheurs
d'emploi des contrats uniques
d'insertion pour des missions sociales
environnementales et sanitaires
ludovic a rejoint la structure il y a
trois ans aujourd'hui il est chef
d'equipe le soleil est à peine levé et
c'est déjà l'effervescence sur le
parking du glaive cette association
intervient auprès des personnes âgées ou
handicapées qui n'ont plus les moyens
physiques ni financiers d'entretenir
leur terrain devant le local technique
rotofil souffleur et râteaux passe de
main en main tous les matins ça se passe
comme ça on a réussi à ses heures et
lieux sûrs pour les aussie alors
magasins et puis on va sur un choc
il est à peine 7 heures lorsque ludovic
et ses collègues arrivent chez la
bénéficiaire du jour là même la
propriétaire est à peine levé mais
accueille avec empressement l'équipe du
globe
miyem habite ici depuis presque 60 ans
autrefois entourés d'un mari et de six
enfants elle vit désormais seul sur ce
grand terrain et a par contre je
m'occupe plus du gendarme ans je faisais
je payais pour le gros et puis j'étais
dedans mais frau était d'une beauté mais
là maintenant ça me fait bien longtemps
ça fait une dizaine d'années que je suis
comme ça au fur et à mesure je deviens
de plus en plus handicap échange
généralisé
l'urgence aujourd'hui coupé la route et
là des quelques branches pour des
raisons esthétiques mais aussi pour des
raisons sanitaires
si la végétation est trop dense la
prolifération de larves de moustiques
pourrait favoriser l'apparition
d'épidémies comme le chikungunya ou
musica c'est ludovic qui gère
l'intervention issu d'une formation en
électrotechnique il n'était pas
prédestiné à travailler dans les espaces
verts mais plusieurs mois de chômage
l'ont poussé à trouver une autre voie
dans ce métier là ça c'est pas donc pas
fallu retourner bonne chose au départ
c'est un contrat de ses 8 ans
renouvelable deux ans et puis voilà ça a
commencé comme ça qu'on fait bien prêts
ou des fois
dans d'autres métiers ainsi d'un côté ça
se débloque enfin
mais s'il faut pas avoir peur faut
essayer un essai plutôt concluant après
deux ans de contrat aidé ludovic vient
de signer un cdi en tant que chef
d'equipe une victoire pour le dionysien
mais aussi pour le glaive car
l'insertion et la première mission de
l'association 10 heures dans le jardin
le travail avance bien la tâche peut
être physique et pendant les pauses
l'équipe peut compter sur la
bienveillance de la maîtresse des lieux
c'est ce qui nous fait aussi en
rencontrant toujours à tous les gens les
mêmes personnes toujours a toujours aimé
les discussions bloquées
ça s'appelait gré des rencontres et des
échanges pour les employés du glaive un
lien avec la société est un vrai coup de
pouce économique pour madame li m6 était
pas le glaive je sais pas comment on
aurait fait à manger on peut toujours en
avoir la pension arrive on achète sont
mangés puis voilà ça va mais le fait pub
qui apprécie peu les à côtés quand on
est tout seul est vieux on a besoin
toutes sortes de services que le
gouvernement ne peut pas tout payer
votre placement des bougies mais bon
j'ai un petit peu company or les
personnes ludovic ne compte pas
s'arrêter là
il suit actuellement une formation en
élagage au sein du glaive et vise
toujours plus haut en 2015 le glaive est
intervenu auprès de 1965 fanny et à
évacuer près de 2000 tonnes de déchets
le créole il a mis sa petite cour il a
souvent des fleurs mais surtout des
arbres et quand on vieillit ou quand on
est personnes porteuses d'un handicap ou
de l'érable on a des difficultés après à
élaguer le glaive est une association
qui a été mise en place pour avec un
double objectif aider les personnes
vulnérables pour que l'on puisse couper
un arbre élaguer entretenir on
ce sont les gros travaux et en même
temps permettre à des jeunes d'être
formé de devenir des professionnels
donc il y a derrière cet objectif
l'objectif de la formation
professionnelle en créant des équipes
dédiées avec un vrai savoir en 2015 le
glaive à proposer 190 contrats aidés
pour postuler au glaive
il faut être bénéficiaires du rsa et
être inscrits au pôle emploi pour
bénéficier gratuitement des actions du
glaive
il faut réunir les conditions suivantes
être physiquement et financièrement
incapable de réaliser les travaux
demandés être non imposable
pour plus de renseignements candidats
comme bénéficiaires peuvent se
rapprocher du glaive situé au 36 rue du
général de gaulle à saint denis ou
appeler au 02 62 41 41 41